hi guys it's me quinn and as always if
you appreciate my content consider
hitting the like button it's the only
way the youtube algorithm really notices
me so i'm a day or so late getting to
this but taika watiti just announced
that he's going to be directing an inkle
movie
now i've known taika mostly for his
comedy
but i do know that he is a competent
writer and a passionate creative
the inkle is joe darowski's masterpiece
it's been ripped off a bunch of times by
a bunch of different movies including
but not limited to star wars and the
fifth element
jodorowsky was actually inspired to
write the inkle
many years after his would-be dune movie
kind of unraveled he took all of the
ideas that he had for that movie and
kind of mixed them around and put them
into the ankle
now there are three ankle books before
the ankle
the ankle
and the final inkle
the inkle was the first in the series to
be published and the art is done by
mobius one of the greatest comic book
artist of all time
the other two books were published after
mobius death so the art is different
still good but different the inco is a
space opera like you've never seen one
before it is possibly the weirdest most
unique sci-fi universe that i've ever
encountered the book revolves around
everyone's pursuit of the ankle the most
valuable object in the entire universe
the object elevates whoever bears it to
the highest form of themself as well as
doing all sorts of other weird and
trippy things though i love the inkle
and it's one of my favorite graphic
novels ever at this point i've even
reviewed it here on this channel i
didn't necessarily expect this to be the
next thing to be getting adapted now
since the success of doom we've heard
about the adaptation of hyperion which
is also doing inspired but hyperion to
me is something that lends itself to
adaptation a lot easier than the ankle
the inco is a weird story and it's
definitely not for everyone so it'll be
interesting to see how this unfolds from
here now jodorowsky of course does have
his other big graphic novel the meta
barons which is actually a lot more
doing inspired than the inkle in fact i
would say this is where he put the
majority of his dune ideas the meta
barons and the inkle actually takes
place in the same universe but the meta
barons is focused specifically on the
character the meta baron and you know
where he came from and like the history
of his lineage
i'm interested to see who will play the
main character john the fool and yes his
name is intentional essentially this
character is archetypically the fool so
he's walking through the universe kind
of with his eyes closed he's kind of
wondering and he's just kind of
receiving things and things are
happening to him the character to me not
just because of the way he's drawn
although that had a lot to do with it
but also the way he's betrayed reminds
me so much of the character philip j fry
from futurama who is kind of also the
fool character he's kind of the most
important man in the universe at the
same time but he's also kind of a fool
so i wouldn't be surprised if that
character from futurama is actually
based on john the fool from the inkle a
little bit i absolutely wish tyka
wattidi the best on this project from
what i hear jodorowsky is also closely
involved with the production if i'm
being honest i have no idea how it's
going to go because i don't know if you
can fit the entire ankle story into a
single movie perhaps but you would have
to cut a bunch and also what i would
wonder would be what is the budget on
this because the ankle is a huge story
it's got scope like dune and star wars
so this is this would be a pretty big
budget thing to portray the ankle
accurately and i just hope that they can
pull it off and like i said it's
interesting that taika is attached to
this because i'm more familiar with his
comedy work but the inkle itself does
have that kind of underlying
layer of comedy i think as well so i'll
see how that expresses itself in his
movie
that being said we're living in exciting
times right now that so much cool and
interesting science fiction is being
adapted right now the foundation show is
happening on apple tv and though it's
not really been my cup of tea i haven't
seen the last few episodes i kind of
fell off i'm still happy that that has a
place and of course i'm really happy
about dune on the hyperion movie or tv
show that's getting made if you want to
learn more about interesting science
fiction lore check out my channel for
more videos all of my different series
are organized neatly into playlists
thanks guys
you